j'espère que tu fais autre chose maintenant
c'est bien d'accord mais continue juste un
peu plus sur la jupe rocheuse Je veux que
tu partes et Rosie c'est tellement agréable tu
sais plus léger l'image ici peux tu
grimper d'accord le grimpeur est ajouté tu
devrais faire quelque chose sur  le sol je
ne peux pas les gars c'est que la glace Luke Luke oh
il est sympa le rocher tu as la fusée
mais je vois comme une belle belle belle
je veux montrer ça encore avec mon appareil photo
donc ton peuple Rahmani si on grimpe pour
te montrer tout  le spectacle tout la pensée de
toi va faire le précédent leurs yeux d'
angles bleus
repartent d'ici te chercher en train de
cueillir ces inachevés ouais ok toi
tu travailles au sol sur le terrain le
morceau du sol est magnifique ils
veulent faire pareil  chose pour moi de
te montrer où ce gentil jaune
voulait te présenter tu cherches
ton peuple et je suis content de ce qu'on a
mais toi juste tu fais juste ce que tu
veux faire yard est pour toi pour toi pour le
film reprendre quand  nous arrivons c'est bon ouais
maintenant je'  je suis content de tout avec les yeux de Dieu d'
accord donc il n'y a pas de problème mais c'est
très gentil quand il est arrivé nous partons
avec un avertissement
oh parce que tu l'as eu ou
quoi d'autre si tu fais la photo une photo
des yeux
pourquoi c'est sale comme ça  mais les volcans
de trucs je veux tirer ça oh ça oh
merde ok non non ok ok merci ok
ok on peut tourner maintenant
Darla ouais où c'est les gens dans le
ciel prends le bleu ok coupe le mets un
filtre sur amateur kardama trois ok
Je devrai la regarder quand nous
reviendrons
parce qu'il est le pouvoir de vos yeux
du sol, il a un César la ligne de
la tour
ouais aussi une partie de la carrière ISIS
fait comme ça alors après on a l'impression que
je suis sûr  ils sont ouais
ils sont fermés de près d'accord mon pote
c'est une bonne
glace colorée au coin ici nous avons un
flair pour les zones redescendues est
parti maintenant d'
accord arrête il y a une compétence il y a
généralement vraiment du
théâtre c'est agréable à dire  vous c'est agréable de
travailler sur ce
crier le wi  nner de l'autre
comme ça alors qu'ils sont allés ricaner et moi
qu'est-ce que c'est que d'arrêter d'enregistrer de nos
sept chanceux
bien vous lancez du bruit du bruit oui
maître oui allez là-bas et tournez à droite
et lancez-le
ouais gardez le sujet c'est ici à venir
ici tu veux avoir un spectacle ce bâillement d'
accord juste comme laisse-moi ralentir un
peu ouais je regarde notre direction à trois
heures ouais alors ça
disparaît là-bas comme d'accord ici
va à l'eau comme une course
Chrysler  Classic USA Indian tu es là
oui il l'est maintenant donc il faut suivre pour en
prendre un à Detroit je pense que c'est mieux
d'aller à l'envers car ouais on pourrait le
mettre à Foot stream au niveau du ruisseau au
moins tu tournes à gauche
ouais d'accord d'accord chacun  l'autre était un travail que j'ai
pris longtemps comme ça tu peux aller comme ça
littéralement suivre le grand d'accord ouais
aussi bien que le mariage de la graisse oh oui oui
pouvons-nous faire demi-tour et le faire voler
ouais - est-ce bien faisons un
peu comme  que pouvons-nous faire demi-tour, nous
devons le faire maintenant est-ce assez t  hé
faisions l'autre côté chignon en arrière tirons d'
accord ouais tu veux la cabine oh oui monte
tout de suite ouais maintenant sur le côté gauche
ouais ouais faisons-le
nous suivons la rivière d'accord mais sur le côté gauche l'
un de l'autre était un hélicoptère
dans la cuisine sympa de voir l'espoir de
bouger tu vois partout tu as
tout puis j'en suis sorti aujourd'hui
et ça disparait ici tu as
le support pour tenir tes cheveux ouais
ça me manque ce truc là ouais et tous ces
jolis arbres à  le spectacle va toujours alors
attends je veux voir ça va à tous oui d'
accord je vais l'horreur va ici
ouais Rick tu l'as maintenant ouais ouais
avant que vous n'arriviez ici d'
accord mystique tu le vois ouais d'accord je
veux faire  ensemble on a encore une bonne
et on baise le tout et on fait qu'est-ce
que tu veux faire tu aimes si
j'aime j'aime refaire le même coup d'
accord d'accord pour prendre de la stabilité chérie maintenant
ouais se tromper parce que je sais  Je pourrais
empiler mon ami glace merci frère
j'ai été  sur la glace trop de fois
personne n'est dans le I sweet ils sont assis à environ
510 mètres vous pouvez le sentir
c'est pourquoi mais sinon c'est fini d'accord
vous pouvez commencer ici en haut c'est comme si
nous avions besoin de voir où nous sommes nous devons
voir l'horizon vers le haut  ici d'accord je ne me
rapproche pas plus haut non non non comme
bas bas et lent vraiment envie de le
refaire parce qu'alors je coupe ce bon
suivons ceci suivez la corde vers
la droite un peu plus
ouais ouais ouais Yuri toi  mets un peu de
difficulté au milieu c'est mon oncle
Isis c'est de l'eau de fond beaucoup d'eau
ici mais là je ne dis pas la même
je pense que c'est une autre il y en a une
autre je pense que c'est ton eau potable
mère y a 10 000 ans  vieille
base d'eau potable le trou tu vois le trou
oh non tu suis paula continue de suivre en
fait trouve tout le but de ne pas en
sauver un tu sais que ça pourrait être
différent ouais je pense que c'est pareil oui tu
dis que ça a l'air plus grand
je pense que le monde
tu sais que la rivière a l'air grosse  euh je vais
vous dire ouais mais j'ai besoin d'un trou au-dessus de ce
briquet la rivière est plus grande
ouais mais je pense que c'est l'émergent
ici qui vient vers le grand
maintenant là-bas parce qu'il vient maintenant de
ce sens ici ici est le  trou ouais
ouais
quelqu'un ici doit juste s'arrêter avant que
le trou ne soit ici merci n'est pas un coffre-fort
est un autre ouais est un autre
ouais le grand trou s'est arrêté ici
oh ouais le prochain est de la prochaine
rivière très  très bien pour nous ce que nous faisons
maintenant est exactement ce que vous êtes venu faire ici d'
accord très gentil merci faites-le gentiment euh
Peter c'est très très important ici
encore c'est une bonne affaire nous allons bien mais faites-
le moi-même maintenant de mon côté s'il
vous plaît nous  prendra des petits événements ensuite oh je
voulais faire la même rivière juste pour moi à partir de
flip photo photo s'il vous plaît ce que ça ira
un peu plus haut pour moi ouais nous
devons prendre des alliés à l'intérieur ce n'est pas
encore sympa à vérifier pour prendre le bon
entraîneur  tu parles comme ça c'est oh ouais d'
accord prends le bon entraîneur
hey  avec le prix entre le même après je
veux voler un peu c'est un gros
nous en sommes un autre je veux être aller sur
celui-ci ça ne prendra pas ouais d'accord je
ne fais pas de photos de la même nourriture et ça
vole vraiment  pouvez-vous essayer un peu ici
Oh,
alors ce que nous tournions maintenant, beaucoup
de gens en parlent ne pensent jamais qu'ils
vont graver une image sur la peau à
nouveau, ils recommencent s'il y a un
désolé, je vais utiliser un grand manses  et
je me rends compte que c'est bien bien je pourrais je ne peux pas
non plus d'
accord je ne peux pas écouter d'accord d'
accord nous allons comme mettre notre petit peu là
descendre de ce côté non non non non je veux dire mon
Dieu d'accord d'accord donc si tu montes un
peu  tu ne peux pas détester ici oui d'
accord comme ça c'est mieux pour moi l'ayah
c'est mieux mais pour Peters c'était bien
ouais qu'est-ce que c'est toute ta glace
là-bas ça vient maintenant je le vois alors
continuons parce que tu la vois tu as été
plus haut
Fei  purge là tu vois je peux la voir
Sophia une voir les deux Reber aller ouais
les deux trous là qui font un im  l'âge jusqu'à
la fin et puis le petit à
droite ça disparaît dans l'idée
comment voler surtout sera plus haut d'accord allez
au début très grande armée vient par la
fenêtre c'est tellement plus haut je pense pas
plus haut je suis de la glace aussi loin  comme des pistolets et je
viens partager un chahuteur ça ok ce
bruit tu vois la rivière
Jupiter
on est plutôt bien dedans
ok - Jim - toux désolé - minute
ah oui ouais pas facile avec cette vidéo ou
ce genre de volet
ok on peut  allez comme ça d'accord on va
au mur maintenant ou on peut d'
accord merci Inca c'est un jour férié je
veux une horloge d'accord va à ta dernière
gauche maintenant testons ça et tu essaies de
me montrer le trou c'est pas très facile je
sais
d'accord là-bas ouais 10 heures
là ouais d'accord mais le trou
arrive maintenant
juste passable pour Peter d'accord spécial
tout d'abord nos gens ont compris est-ce que tu es
allé à peu près tout d'accord mais moi je
ne peux pas tu penses que tu peux  tire ok juste
un ordinateur
on vient de naître ta vie c'est bien
pour toi je ca  n voyez ouais c'est bien d'accord d'
accord fantastique d'
accord c'est bon allez expliquer à nouveau exactement
c'est incroyable pour nous agréable d'avoir une
réflexion d'expert sur l'eau c'est bon je l'
ai c'est bien choisir votre temps et
après vous pouvez aller à la rivière
devant vous, vous savez si je mets juste une
horloge dans vous pouvez n'est-ce pas que notre triangle
au tout dans je ne sais pas est très
agréable un très heureux
cette nuit même nous a envoyé des informations
Oscar or kilo position
ouais  nous travaillons autour de la position six
un zéro Niner portes et quatre six un
et Niner West et ensuite parce que pour vous
trois zéro d'accord c'est
tellement bien
peut-être que nous nous envolons maintenant et je vais faire un
zoom arrière nous trouverons des garçons et je
m'habitue  s'envoler maintenant l'a prise pour toi
ouais encore passer à autre chose j'ai soif mon ami
merci beaucoup
Oh Tommy ça reste pour moi papa d'
accord ils ont arrêté d'enregistrer à partir de
je vais prendre leur diplôme d'histoires sociales
récupérer et si tu y vas  en bas on
suivait les eaux et les yeux c'est bleu
magnifique ça a été  o sois un gros partout
car y'a bref je pense qu'ils
étaient là
on va suivre la rivière qui
descend hein ok merci pour le
niveau bas ou perdre mon faux peut etre commencer à
descendre par dessus et descendre ça en bas de la
rivière
oui c'est une rivière qui coule dans ou hors de
ce Dysport dans une sortie parce que c'est le
grand qui est créé pour fonctionner verticalement par rapport
aux autres près de partout ouais c'est
toujours bon de savoir si j'étais tu
veux aller oui nous le titulaire a  être pour
les eaux qui disparaissent tout
ça fond partout il y a beaucoup de points communs à l'eau l'enfer d'une promenade d'autres personnes qui marchent maintenant ou font du
ski ou ce
meilleur
profond très profond immigrant à la liste
commandez le gars directement ici
ouais nous avons dû voler un peu  comme ça
parce que c'est à nouveau avec le bas donc
nous glissons juste vers la droite maintenant le
cou va tenir regarde ouais ouais ouais
bouge - sacré grand trou sympa je pense que le
trou est là-bas parce qu'il a continué
comme décrit aussi un peu donc  nous pouvons
mettre je  pense que celui est là de toute façon d'
accord d'accord tu viens ici maintenant ouais
ouais ouais ouais c'est un gros
tu sais s'ils ont parlé plus tôt ouais
mets juste au milieu d'elle a une
ombre d'hélicoptère de cette direction d'
accord
tout le gros klaxon mon  dieu d'accord maintenant ouais ah
c'est fantastique nous devons avoir un
hélicoptère des ombres juste là d'accord ouais
ouais et c'est une bonne idée Beckwith de retour
contre le soleil non tu peux voir les plus vieux
ouais tu veux revenir pour voir euh je suis
un sauna pense  nous montons la diapositive vous
savez que nous sommes d'un côté ou de
l'autre très bien que je pense que
j'aimerais le refaire mais tronquer la
colline accomplie flèche air ok le
monde où suivre l'Ohio nous
devrions  être plus haut
je suppose qu'il faut être haut ouais d'
accord on recommence toute la liste je
pense que tu seras plus spectaculaire
en haut
et des choses comme ça on suit on y va
doucement ça pèse le fond de la merde
que j'ai  le sucre alors et je vais juste le
résoudre,
je pense que ce sont des sha  re de ceux-ci
vont être à propos de la peur d'accord
tout à fait des trucs pour la glace vous pouvez être
Bora le regretté n'a pas de Rosie Rosie - oh
vous savez que je veux essayer un
tir en contre-jour juste en planant d'
accord monsieur inclinez-vous vers le bas n'allez pas à  le
tout monte d'
accord pouvons-nous juste aller un autre ici 100
mètres tout de suite nous sommes à vous arrêter
pour partir mon ami c'est ce voyage
ce que je veux faire non plus je veux ajouter
je pense que les coups se passent
trop lentement ce que je  'aimerais faire, c'est juste
faire demi-tour et regarder en arrière d'
ici parce qu'il y aura beaucoup de
reflets de l'eau d'accord, donc nous
partirons d'ici et nous le ferons
juste d'ici d'accord d'ici je
regarde  de leurs dents s'asseoir
au trou ici d'
accord hé je ne peux pas l'avoir avec ça
Merci d'accord plus sur votre droite s'il vous plaît
pour moi maintenant d'accord laissez-moi plonger un peu
avec la ligne donc ils sont plus faciles pour moi et
tenez pour  moi commençant par là pouvons-nous aller sur
votre gauche si vous le gardez là-haut comme
ça ' qui est le ho  le de mon côté tu
repars et vas te battre à tes côtés je
ne connais pas l'égalité dans ce bois mais
moins tu y vas tu peux le garder je peux dire
ça de la même manière et tu vas tu vas
comme ça est tombé pile sur le  côté droit
désolé désolé désolé ouais laisse-moi partir
un peu avec nous ou on peut faire le tour si tu
veux que ce soit plus facile pour moi de traîner comme ça
mais aller partout ouais ouais ouais parce que
tu devais être témoin que plus facile tu
dois rentrer chez toi sur ton  regarde parce que je suis
proche d'accord entre égoïste renverser
encore renverser encore ok ok parfait
parfait exactement ce que je veux c'est bon
ok on monte un peu je veux voir
brasser ok on peut peut-être passer par là est-ce que
ça va changer les diamants de bande
je comprends  maintenant alcalis elle fait la
caméra